Thank you, Dr. Campbell, Dr. Zakir Naik,
for your presentations as well as the
response.
Lastly, we have the audience
participation session, namely, the
question and answer session.
To extract maximum benefit in the
limited time of 60 minutes,
approximately, that we have available,
we would like the following rules to be
observed.
Your question should be only on the
topic, The Quran and the Bible
in the light of the subject of science.
Questions out of the topic would not be
entertained.
Kindly state your question briefly and
to the point.
This is not a lecture time,
neither a counter question time for the
questioners.
Dr. William Campbell and Dr. Zakir Naik
should answer comprehensively,
and each answer should not exceed 5
minutes.
Four mics have been provided in the
auditorium for the questions from the
mics.
Two
next to the stage for the gents, and two
in the rear of the center aisles for the
ladies.
Those who'd like to put forward a
question to Dr. William Campbell
may kindly queue up behind the mics on
my left, gents in the front, ladies in
the rear. And those who would like to
put forward a question to Dr. Zakir may
kindly line up behind the mics on my
right, gents in the front, and the
ladies in the rear.
I would like the audience in the balcony
to kindly excuse us.
We are happy that this is a full
session, jam-packed hall, but we'd
request you to kindly take the trouble
to come down to the mics if you'd like
to put forward a question.
Only one question at a time may be put
forward.
If you have a second question, you would
have to line up behind
again to put forward your second
question.
Written questions on index cards
available from the volunteers in the
aisles
would be given secondary preference
after the questions on the mics are
handled by the speakers.
Please write on the card to whom your
question is addressed, Dr. William
Campbell or Dr. Zakir Naik, so that they
can be put in the appropriate boxes in
front of you, transparent boxes with the
names Dr. William Campbell and Dr. Zakir
Naik put on them,
so that the questions
could be shaken up
by the coordinators and the speakers
themselves could select the questions at
random.
These would be screened by the panel
of the speakers
to see that they're relevant and on the
topic and okayed by the coordinators to
be put forward on the coordinator's mic,
which the speakers would have to answer.
Kindly state your name and profession
before putting forward your question.
We will allow one question at a time in
a zigzag fashion alternately addressed
to each speaker.
So, first question next to the stage,
second question next to the stage, third
question on my left in the rear, fourth
question in the rear on my right, and so
on.
We would allow
approximately 40 minutes for these
questions, then we switch over to the
questions on the slips. May we have the
first question from the mic on my left
for Dr. William Campbell.
I would like to ask Dr. Campbell if uh
in Genesis
it says when it talks about the flood,
Noah flood,
it talks about that the water covered
the surface of the earth,
all the creations and all the mountains
and everything.
And it says that it covers the highest
mountain of on earth,
and that was 15 cubits,
which is in Arabic 15 ft,
you know, kadam.
So, we know scientifically that the
highest mountain on earth is not 15 ft,
you know, it is a lot higher than that.
So, how come the in Genesis it says that
the water covered everything, every
single mountain on earth, and the
highest was 15 ft?
Thank you for your question.
I think it's saying that that is above
the highest mountain.
If the highest mountain is 3,000 m,
well, then the higher then it's 15 ft
over 15 ft above it.
However,
Uh brother will not allow any questions
in between. No counter questions,
please. Let the questioner put his
question, full stop. Then the speaker
gives his answer in whatever manner he
chooses. Thank you.
And I looked into this uh in the car in
the car and I think it actually would be
understood to be the same way because it
says in Sura 11, verse 40, the fountains
of the earth gushed forth,
and the waves like mountains. And then
it says that in in
in the places where it gives a list of
prophets, there's no prophet before
Noah.
It And so, if I know Adam can be a
prophet, but I'm
So, Noah is is listed, and I think that
it says in the car and too that the
whole world was covered.
Yes, brother.
Question for Dr. Zakir Naik. Dr. Zakir,
you say that there isn't any mistake
me. Excuse me. The second question would
come from the mic on my right for Dr.
Zakir.
Okay, um you said that Allah reflects
light
and um he's made of noor.
I didn't really understand that.
The brother posed a question. He didn't
understand my explanation
to the
counter argument of
Dr. William Campbell.
Regarding noor and Allah.
The Quran says in Surah Noor chapter 24
verse number 35 that Allah is noor as
samawati wal ard. Is the light of the
heavens and the earth.
He's a light.
The meaning of light
in the Quran
it is
reflected light
or borrowed light.
So, he's asking, does it mean that even
Allah has got borrowed light?
So, the answer he's giving further if
you read in the verse, it says that it's
like a parable of a niche. In the niche
there is a lamp. Lamp has the light of
its own.
That means Allah has light of its own as
well as that light of its own is also
being reflected.
The light of Allah subhana wa ta'ala is
again being reflected by Allah subhana
wa ta'ala himself. Like a halogen lamp
that you see here. It has a tube in
between.
The lamp you can refer to that as a
siraj or a wahaj or a diya and the
reflector as munir or noor borrowed
light or reflection of light.
And furthermore, but natural this light
actually doesn't refer to the physical
light we're talking about. It is the
spiritual light of Allah subhana wa
ta'ala. But as I answer I've given to
Dr. William Campbell
and since I've got 5 minutes I'd like to
utilize it.
Dr. William Campbell
gave a reply to Noah alaihis salaam. I'm
a person who's a concordist approach
with the Bible and conflict approach
with the Quran
because both way alhamdulillah Quran
will pass the test and even if I agree
with Dr. William Campbell and I agree
with him, it is right that it was 15 ft
above the highest mountain. But it's
mentioned in Genesis chapter number 7
verse number 19 and 20 that the full
world was submerged under water.
And furthermore,
archaeological evidence show us today
and the time of Noah's time if you
calculate by genealogy, it comes to in
the 21st to 22nd century BC.
Archaeological evidence show us today
that the third dynasty of Babylon and
11th dynasty of Egypt were present at
the 21st and 22nd century BC and there
was no evidence of flood and they remain
uninterrupted. Therefore, archaeological
evidence show us that it's impossible
that the earth was submerged the full
earth was submerged under water in the
21st 22nd century BC.
What about the Quran?
Point number one, Quran does not give a
date.
Whether 21st
century BC or 50th century BC, no date.
Point number two, nowhere does the Quran
say the full world was submerged under
water. It speaks about Noah alaihi
salaam and his قوم and his people.
A small group of people or maybe a large
group of people.
Archaeological evidences tell today and
the archaeologists they say that we have
no objection, it's possible that parts
of the world was submerged under water,
but full world it's not possible. So
alhamdulillah, the Quran is matching
with the latest discovery in
archaeology, but the Bible does not.
Furthermore, if you read Genesis chapter
number 6 verse number 15 16, it speaks
about Almighty God telling Noah alaihi
salaam that build an ark and it gives
the length, 300 cubit in length, 50
cubit in breadth and height 30 cubit.
Cubit is 1 and 1/2 ft. The brother made
a mistake.
It's 1 and 1/2 ft and the New
International Version it says 450 ft in
length
and 75 ft in breadth and approximately
45 ft in height. It's 30 cubit in
height.
If you measure this, I've done the
calculation, it comes to less than
150,000
cubic feet in volume.
And area-wise, 33,750.
And the Bible says there were three
floors. Ground floor, first story,
second story. So, multiply by three, you
get the answer of 101,250
square feet.
That is area. Imagine a pair of all the
species of the world was accommodated in
101,250
square feet. Imagine.
Is it possible? Millions of species are
there in the world?
If I tell you in this auditorium
1 million people came in this
auditorium, will you believe?
I remember
I think last year, I'd given a talk in
Kerala, and there were 1 million people.
That's the biggest gathering I've ever
addressed, alhamdulillah, by Allah's
grace. 1 million people, I COULD NOT SEE
THE END. IT WAS NOT AN AUDITORIUM, it
was a big beach. I couldn't see anyone.
Only few people in the front, that's
all. Few compared to the 1 million
people that were there. If you see on
the video cassette, you will realize how
big is 1 million. Somewhat like Arafat,
you see 2 and 1/2 million people in
Arafat.
In a area of 101,250
square feet, or 150,000 cubic feet, IT
IS IMPOSSIBLE. AND ABOVE THAT, THEY
STAYED FOR 40 DAYS.
EATING, going for call of nature.
If I tell 1 million people came in this
auditorium, will you believe?
So, scientifically, there are several
things in which there are gross
scientific errors in the Bible.
Can we have the next question for Dr.
Campbell from the mic at the rear?
Dr. Naik, you said that
excuse me.
This question is for Dr. Campbell.
Okay.
So, you have to wait.
So, the next person who'd like to ask a
question to Dr. for Dr. Campbell. Yes.
I'd like to pose this question, or
rather
uh this test to Dr. William Campbell,
"Why don't you attempt the falsification
test of the Bible given in the book of
Mark
chapter 16
verses 17 and 18
and prove to the audience here
right now
that you are a true
Christian believer."
Well, I don't agree with Dr. Naik's
interpretation.
God's Jesus himself was tempted.
And devil said, "Well, if you're the son
of God, throw yourself off the temple."
And Jesus said, "You will not tempt the
Lord your God."
And so if I was to dare and say, "Oh,
yes, I'm going to be sure and do a
miracle in front of you."
I would be tempting God.
My friend, Harry Radcliffe, he had
promised to go.
And so he decided to keep his promise
and
trust God to do his will.
It's a different situation. I will not
tempt God.
Right. Thank you.
Question for Dr. Naik.
Maybe we have the question in the rear.
From the sister. She's She's for Dr.
Naik.
Or Campbell. At the back.
Do you have a question for Dr. Naik in
the back, ladies? Yes. Okay. Um my
question is to Dr. Zakir Naik. The
Christians explain the concept of
Trinity scientifically by giving the
example of water, which can be in three
states, solid, liquid, and gas in the
form of ice, water, and vapor.
Similarly, one God is a tri- triune God,
Father, Son, and Holy Ghost. Is this
explanation scientifically correct?
Just a comment before I give the answer.
We should not tempt God. We should not
test God. But here we aren't testing
God.
We are testing the human being.
We should not test God. But here we are
testing you and God promises that any
believer who has deadly poison he will
not die. He'll be able to speak in
foreign tongues. We aren't testing God,
we know God is correct. He will see to
it that every believer can speak. We are
testing you whether you're a believer or
not.
Coming to the question
of the sister
that
there are Christians who say that
scientifically we can prove the concept
of trinity
like how water can be in three states,
solid, liquid, and gas.
Like ice, water, and vapor. So,
similarly God is in three forms.
Father, Son, and Holy Ghost.
How do you reply and is this
scientifically correct?
Scientifically I do agree water can be
in three forms. Solid, liquid, and gas.
Ice,
water, and vapor. But, scientifically we
also know that the component of water
remains the same, H2O. Two atoms of
hydrogen and one atom of oxygen. The
components remain the same.
The constituent remain the same. The
forms keep on changing. There is no
problem. Let's check with the concept of
trinity.
Concept of trinity.
Father, Son, and Holy Ghost. Form, they
say form changes.
Okay, for sake of argument we agree.
Does the component change?
God and Holy Ghost is made of spirit.
You and me are made of flesh and bones.
They aren't the same.
You and me require to eat.
God doesn't require to eat to survive.
They aren't the same.
And this is testified by Jesus Christ,
peace be upon him, himself in the Gospel
of Luke, chapter number 24, verse number
36 to 39.
He says
that behold my hands and feet. Handle me
and see for a spirit has no flesh and
bones.
He says, behold my hands and feet.
Handle me and see for a spirit has no
flesh and bone. And he gave his hand and
they saw and they were overjoyed.
And he said that do you have any meat to
eat? And they gave him broiled fish and
a piece of honeycomb. And he ate to
prove what? That he was God? To prove
that HE WAS NOT GOD. HE ATE.
AND HE FLESH and bones. A spirit has got
no flesh and bone. This proves that it
is scientifically not possible that
Father, Son, and Holy Ghost, Father
Jesus Christ peace be upon him, Holy
Ghost is almighty God. And the concept
of Trinity, the word Trinity
doesn't exist anywhere in the Bible. The
word Trinity is not there in the Bible,
but it is there in the Quran.
Quran says in Surah Nisa, chapter 4,
verse 171, it says, "Walat taqulu
salasa. Don't say Trinity. Intahu
khairul lakum. This is stop it better
for you."
Trinity is also there in Surah Maidah,
chapter number 5,
verse number 73, which says, "Laqad
kafara alladhina qalu innallaha salisu
salasa. THEY ARE DOING KUF. They are
blaspheming, those who say that Allah is
three in one, is a triune God."
Jesus Christ peace be upon him, NEVER
SAID HE WAS GOD. The concept of Trinity
doesn't exist in the Bible. The only
verse which is closest to the concept of
Trinity is the first epistle of John,
chapter number 5, verse number 7, which
says, "For there are three that bear
record in heaven, the Father, the Word,
and the Holy Ghost, and these three are
one." But if you read the Revised
Standard Version, revised by Titus
scholars, Christian scholars of the
highest eminence, backed by 50 different
corporate denominations, they say this
verse of the Bible, first epistle of
John, chapter 5, verse number 7, is an
interpolation, is a concoction, is a
fabrication. It was thrown out of the
Bible.
Jesus Christ peace be upon him, never
claimed divinity. There is not a single
unequivocal statement in the complete
Bible where Jesus Christ peace be upon
him says, "I'm God," or where he says,
"Worship me." In fact, if you read the
Bible, it is mentioned in the Gospel of
John, chapter number 14, verse number
28, he said, "My father is greater than
I." Gospel of John, chapter number 10,
verse number 29, my father is greater
than all. Gospel of Matthew chapter
number 12 verse number 28, I cast out
devils with the spirit of God. Gospel of
Luke chapter number 11 verse number 20,
I with the finger of God cast out devil.
Gospel of John chapter number five verse
number 30, I can of my own SELF DO
NOTHING.
I CAN OF MY OWN SELF DO NOTHING. AS I
HEAR, I JUDGE AND MY JUDGMENT IS JUST
FOR I SEEK NOT MY WILL BUT THE WILL OF
MY FATHER. Anyone who says not my will
but God's will, he's a Muslim. Muslim
means a person who submits his will to
almighty God. Jesus Christ peace be upon
him said not my will but God's will. He
was a Muslim and he was alhamdulillah
one of the mightiest messenger of God.
We believe
We believe that he was born miraculously
without any male intervention. We
believe he gave life to the dead with
God's permission. We believe that he
healed those born blind and lepers with
God's permission. We respect Jesus
Christ peace be upon him as one of the
mightiest messenger of God but he is not
God and he is not a part of the trinity.
Trinity doesn't exist. Quran says kul
huwallahu ahad, say he's Allah one and
only.
Uh just a before we have the next
question from the mic here. Earlier I
had announced that the ladies should
kindly queue up there. Unfortunately,
they have not queued up there so we are
having a problem of balancing the
questions. Okay, what we do, we
disregard the labels on the mic. If the
ladies want to ask from here, we'll
allow them. Just balance this in
practical necessity. The hall is
jam-packed, we understand.
We will allow now one question
for Dr.
Campbell from here
and the rear mic will be for people
who'd like to ask question from the
gents for Dr. Zakir. Similarly for the
ladies
the front mic would be for Dr. William
Campbell and the rear mic would be for
Dr. Zakir. Are there people queued there
for Dr. Zakir? Yeah. Yes. Okay. People
queued here for Dr. Campbell?
Right. I think they have taken their own
positions and changed the positions
organizers had given. We respect it
because of the rush in the hall. We'll
take the next question for Dr.
Campbell from this mic. Thank you. Yes,
brother.
As-salamu alaykum.
Um alhamdulillah, tonight's been praise
be to Allah. Praise be to the one God of
all mankind. Tonight's been a very
interesting dialogue. Um and a dialogue
at that. Um
It's talking about uh a very noble uh
topic for mankind.
For all of mankind. And uh so we have
gathered here as men of humanity.
Question. Question, please. No no
Bismillah. Okay. Bismillah. In the name
of Allah.
The question is this. Okay, we've come
here together for this event tonight. It
should benefit us. And and so I'm asking
Dr. Campbell uh as a Christian and and
and with your colleagues as well,
has this event
uh
done its job? Has it opened your heart?
Has it Has it at least uh
opened a glimmer towards looking further
into the truth of Islam? Thank you.
Well, I think I'll use the last question
to answer yours.
Dr. Naik says there's no place that
Jesus says he's God.
In Mark 14:61,
he didn't answer.
And again, the high priest was
questioning him and saying to him,
"Are you the Christ, the son of the
blessed one?"
In other words, "Are you the Christ, the
son of God?
And Jesus said, I am.
So, he did say I'm the son of God.
And he did say he's divine.
And the the the the the the Bible
clearly says, I realize he's quoted the
verses he wished to quote, Dr. Dr. Naik
wished to quote, where Jesus was in his
human form.
But there's other verses. He says, I and
the Father are one.
It says, In the beginning was the word,
and the word was with God, and the word
was God.
And the God and the God and God was made
flesh and dwelt among us.
In Jesus' baptism, the Father spoke and
said, This is my beloved son. Jesus was
there, and the Holy Spirit descended.
The Father, the Son, and the Holy
Spirit. We didn't make this thing up
from our heads. Just look this little
little uh thing. The Our now my the
friend asked the question here.
We We've learned many things,
and I'm always willing to learn,
but I still think that the 500 witnesses
that saw Jesus after he rose from the
dead have more power with me than
Muhammad coming 600 years later as one
witness. Thank you.
We'll allow a question for Dr. Zakir
from the rear.
Yes, sister. Um Dr. Campbell did first
attempt to bring up supposed false facts
uh pertaining to the Quranic views on
the universe, and you did refute these
accusations. However, it was not
addressed what the Bible says about the
shape of the earth and its other
aspects.
Sister asked the question
that I did not address
regarding what the Bible says about the
shape of the earth due to lack of time.
I can point out another 100 points lack
of time.
Anyhow, sister wants to know what does
the Bible speak about the shape of the
earth. It's mentioned
in the Bible, in the Gospel of Matthew,
chapter number 4, verse number 8. It
says
the same reference which Dr. William
Campbell used about tempting.
The devil took him, that Jesus Christ,
peace be upon him, to a exceedingly high
mountain and showed him all the kingdoms
of the earth and its glory. Gospel of
Luke, chapter number 4, verse number 5.
The devil took him to a high mountain
and showed him the glory of all the
kingdoms of the world.
Now, even if you GO TO THE TALLEST
MOUNTAIN, the highest mountain in the
world, that's Mount Everest, and
supposingly, you have a very good vision
and can see for thousands of miles
together, yet
you will not be able to see all the
kingdoms of the world because today we
know the earth is spherical. You will
not be able to see the kingdom of the
opposite side of the world. The only way
you would be able to see if the earth
was flat. That's the description what
the Bible gives. The earth is flat.
Furthermore, the same description is
repeated in the book of Daniel, chapter
number 4, verse number 10 and 11. It
says in a dream that the tree grew up
into the heaven
and there when the tree grew up into the
heaven,
it grew up so much that everyone FROM
ALL THE ENDS OF THE EARTH, they could
see the tree.
This is only possible if the shape of
the earth was flat. If a tree is very
long
and the shape of the earth was flat,
it's possible.
Today, it's a universal fact that the
world is spherical, you will never be
able to see the tree however much long
it is from the opposite side of the
spherical shape of the earth.
Furthermore, if you read, it's mentioned
in
the first Chronicles,
chapter number 16, verse number 30, that
the earth does not move. The same is
repeated in the book of Psalms, chapter
number 93, verse number 1, that almighty
God has stabilized the earth. That means
the earth does not move. And in the New
International Version, it says that God
has established
and stopped the movement of the earth as
though 1 minute the earth is
1 minute left or 1 minute?
1 minute left.
I thought you asked me to wait for 1
minute.
Regarding Dr. William Campbell
he said that Jesus Christ peace be upon
him said in the Bible in several places
that he was God. You can refer to my
video cassette concept of God in major
religion which gives all the references
and the answers. I'll only give you the
references of what you quoted and my
father are one is from John chapter
number 10 verse number 30 and in the
beginning was the word is from John
chapter number 1 verse number 1.
You go to the context and you'll come to
know Jesus Christ peace be upon him
never claimed divinity. You can take my
cassette which is available in the foyer
outside concept of God in major religion
and similarities between Islam and
Christianity which give the details that
Jesus Christ peace be upon him never
claimed divinity. Time. Thank you. The
next question from the lady in the front
for Dr. William.
Um you mentioned the the test where
a true believer can drink poison and
survive because of their faith. What
about uh Rasputin who was poisoned with
enough cyanide to kill 16 people and
when that didn't kill him he died of
blood loss.
He was not a good Christian. He had
orgies.
How do you explain this? Where only a
good Christian can drink this poison and
live. How do you explain that?
Well, I don't feel I have to explain it.
I mean if Rasputin wasn't a Christian
well what happened to him has no basis
for what happened in the Bible. I said
before Jesus God God didn't intend for
us to line up here and start start
taking poison and see whether he's the
true God.
Oh, sorry.
It's we are not to test test God. That
was given that these that said that
these things will happen.
It An example would be Paul.
He went to uh when he was in shipwrecked
and he I think it's Crete, but I have
the wrong place in my mind.
And, uh, and he landed and so he was
throwing wood in the fire and a snake
bit him.
Nothing happened to him. But he wasn't
trying to test God, he was trying to
throw wood in the fire.
So it's a different situation.
No comment, please. Thank you.
The next question from the rear for Dr.
Zakir.
Excuse me. Yes, brother. Excuse me, sir.
Sorry, sorry. Carry on.
I just like to say about the circle of
the earth.
In Isaiah 40:22, it says he, God, sits
enthroned above the circle of the earth.
Thank you. In the back for Dr.
Yes, brother.
For Dr. Zakir. Dr. Zakir, you said there
isn't any mistake in Quran. I see more
than 20 mistake
in Arabic grammar.
And I will tell you some of them.
Brother, what
in Baqarah and
Hajj
Which is right? As-Sabi'un or
As-Sabi'in?
Number one.
Number two. Brother,
brother, one question at a time, please.
Yeah, but are the same thing. He said in
Surah Taha 63, "Inna hadhani
lasahirani." Mistake.
"Inna hadhayni lasahirani."
Can you explain that?
And there is more than that mistakes.
Brother, brother, we'll allow you only
the first part of the question. The
second part we'll not allow because we
have stated we'll allow one question at
a time so others get a chance too. Okay.
The brother has asked a very good
question. I would like to be more
concordant and agreeing. He has
mentioned all 20 grammatical points. And
the book he's referring to by Abdul
Fadi, Abdul Fadi, correct? Is the Quran
infallible? I can see something. Yeah.
Alhamdulillah, my sight is good.
I will ANSWER ALL 20 TOGETHER.
BECAUSE I'VE READ THE BOOK.
I'LL ANSWER ALL 20, INSHALLAH.
INSHALLAH.
Point number one, brother.
Point number one.
Point number one to be noted, that all
Arabic grammar is taken from the Quran.
Quran was the highest Arabic book, a
book which has the maximum level of
highest literature.
All the Arabic grammar has been derived
from the Quran.
Quran is the textbook of grammar. Since
Quran is the textbook of grammar, and
all the grammar is derived from the
Quran, the Quran can never have a
mistake. Point number one.
POINT NUMBER TWO.
IT IS LIKE, you know, taking a ruler,
and the ruler is there has a
measurement, and you're saying the
measurement is wrong.
It sounds illogical. Point number two.
In the different tribes of
Arabia, and you know Arabic, and Dr.
William Campbell also will agree with
me, in different Arabic tribes, the
grammar keeps on changing. In some
Arabic tribe,
the word is feminine, the same word is
even masculine in the other tribes of
Arabia. In different tribes, the grammar
keeps on changing. Even the gender keeps
on changing.
So, will you check Quran with that
faulty grammar? No.
And furthermore, the eloquence OF QURAN
IS SO HIGH.
IT'S SO HIGH, IT IS FAR SUPERIOR. And
you know, there are various books on the
internet, you go. 12 grammatical
mistake, 21 grammatical mistake, Abdul
Fadi, 20 grammatical mistake.
Do you think the Christian people took
out to mistakes? Who took out these
mistakes?
Do you know who took out?
The Muslims. The Muslim scholars, like
Zamakhshari, what they did, that the
Quran GRAMMAR IS SO HIGH THAT IT GOES
AGAINST the conventional use of the
Arabic.
The Quran grammar is so high. To prove
the Quranic grammar was high, they gave
examples. And I'll give you a couple of
examples, which will answer all these 20
questions.
They give the example, like reading the
Quran, it says that the people of Lut
alayhis salaam, they rejected all the
messengers.
They rejected the messengers, it's
mentioned. Dr. William Campbell said,
"The people of Noah, they rejected the
messengers." We know from history that
there was only one messenger sent to
them. So, it has a grammatical mistake.
Quran should have said, "The people
rejected the messenger, not messengers."
I agree with you. With layman grammar,
like how you and I know,
it may be a mistake. But, if you read
the books written by Arabs,
what is the beauty of the Quran? The
beauty of the Quran is, why does the
Quran differ messengers instead of
messenger?
You know why? Because we know that the
basic message of all the messengers was
same, that there is one God, about
tawhid, about Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
By mentioning the people of Lut alayhis
salaam, the people of Noah rejected the
messenger, it says by rejecting Lut
alayhis salaam, they are indirectly
rejecting ALL THE MESSENGERS.
SEE THE BEAUTY. SEE THE ELOQUENCE.
ALHAMDULILLAH.
You may think it's a mistake. It's not a
mistake. Similarly, people like Anis
Shorrosh says that Quran says
kun fayakun, be and it is. It should be
kun fakana, be and it was.
Agreed, past tense is kun fakana in
Arabic. It's not kun fayakun. But, the
kun fayakun is more superior. It says,
"Allah, it was, it is, AND CAN DO."
PAST, PRESENT, AND FUTURE. Thank you,
Dr. Naik.
Uh may we have the next question from
the brother in the front for Dr. William
Campbell. Yes, Dr. Campbell, this is a
very sincere question to learn a little
more about Christianity. Uh I want to
ask that Jesus ministry was only for 3
years after he was baptized by John the
Baptist. So, Jesus, the second most
powerful person after God, the son of
God, what are his contribution in his
early life from first from 1 year to say
27 or 28 years? What are his significant
contributions?
This is uh excuse me, uh Dr. Campbell,
uh this this this is not This is not the
topic for tonight.
We have We had
Yeah, we you can go ahead. Uh in the
beginning of the his presentation, Dr.
Campbell mentioned uh
Zulqarnain from the chapter 18 of Quran,
the cave. Uh and he mentioned that
Zulqarnain is Alexander the Great. Can
you prove me how you came to that that
Zulqarnain is Alexander the Great?
I only read it in the commentary of uh
Yusuf Ali.
I But regardless of whether it's
Alexander the Great or who it is,
the the sun doesn't sit doesn't set in a
murky mar marsh, and that's what it the
first says.
Okay, thank you.
Yes, sister, the question for Dr. Zakir.
I don't know the exact verse, but when
the Bible says, "For as Jonah was 3 days
and 3 nights in the belly of the fish,
so shall the son of man be for 3 days
and 3 nights the heart of the earth."
Did Jesus, peace be upon him,
scientifically fulfill the sign of
Jonah?
What the sister did refer to the verse
of the Bible, Gospel of Matthew, chapter
number 12, verse number 38 and 40, when
people asked Jesus Christ, peace be upon
him, "Show me a sign. Show me a
miracle." Jesus Christ, peace be upon
him, says, "You evil and adulterous
generation, seek it after a sign. No
sign shall be given to you, but the sign
OF JONAH. FOR AS JONAH WAS 3 DAYS and 3
nights in the belly of the whale, so
shall the Son of Man be 3 days and 3
nights in the heart of the earth."
Sign of Jonah. Jesus Christ, peace be
upon him, puts all his eggs
in one basket. And if you go to the sign
of Jonah, the book of Jonah is less than
two pages, and most of us know.
And if you analyze that Jonah was 3 days
and 3 nights,
but Jesus Christ, peace be upon him, we
know from the Gospels that he was put on
the cross, the alleged crucifixion,
alleged.
By late evening, he was brought down
from the cross and put in the sepulcher.
And on Sunday morning, if you see, the
stone is moved away and the sepulcher is
completely empty. So, Jesus Christ,
peace be upon him, is in the tomb on
Friday night.
Friday night he was in the tomb. Friday
night.
He was there in Saturday morning, 1 day,
1 night, 1 day.
And he was there Saturday night. So, two
night and one day. Two night and Sunday
morning the tomb was empty. So, Jesus
Christ, peace be upon him, was there for
two nights and one day. It's not 3 days
and 3 nights. Dr. William Campbell gives
the reply in his book
that you know, part of the day can be
counted as 1 day. And if a patient comes
to me who's sick on Saturday night, on
Monday morning, and if I ask him, "How
long are you sick for?" he will say 3
days.
I agree with you. Concord's approach, I
agree. I'm very generous.
You say part of the day is full day, I
agree with you. So, Saturday night, part
of the day, 1 day. Sunday, part of the
day, full day, 1 good.
Monday, part of the day, full day, no
problem. If patient says 3 days, no
objection. But no patient will ever SAY
3 DAYS AND 3 NIGHTS.
I CHALLENGE. I HAVE ALHAMDULILLAH met
various patients. I have not come across
a single patient, including Christian
missionaries, who have ever told to me
who was sick
in the night of day before yesterday
saying I'm sick for 3 days 3 nights.
So Jesus Christ be with us in 3 days.
Jesus Christ be with us upon us says 3
days and 3 nights.
So it is a mathematical error.
Scientifically Jesus Christ be with us
upon didn't prove. And furthermore the
PROPHECY SAYS AS JONAH WAS SO SHALL the
son of man be. Jonah was how? How was
Jonah in the belly of the whale? Belly
of the fish? DEAD OR ALIVE?
ALIVE. WHEN YOU'RE THROWN OVER BOARD HE
WAS ALIVE. IN THE BELLY OF THE WHALE he
goes around the ocean. Dead or alive?
Alive. He prays TO ALMIGHTY GOD. DEAD OR
ALIVE? ALIVE. HE IS VOMITED OUT ON THE
SEASHORE. DEAD OR ALIVE? Alive alive
alive alive.
When I ask the Christians how was Jesus
Christ be with us upon him in the
sepulcher in the tomb? DEAD OR ALIVE?
They tell me dead.
Alive. Alhamdulillah.
Is there a Christian? IF HE'S ALIVE
ALHAMDULILLAH HE WAS not crucified. If
he's dead he hasn't fulfilled the sign.
You can refer to my video cassette was
Jesus Christ be with us upon really
crucified and proved that Jesus Christ
be with us upon was not crucified as the
Quran says in Surah Nisa chapter 4 157.
They
didn't kill him neither did they crucify
him. It was only made to appear so.
Thank you Dr. Naik. Doctor
Question for Dr. William.
Dr. Campbell since you are a medical
doctor could you please explain
scientifically the various medical
aspects that in the Bible regarding
because you didn't answer them in your
rebuttal. For example blood used as a
disinfectant bitter water test for
adultery and most importantly that the
woman is unclean for double the period
when she gives birth to a daughter than
as compared to a son.
Thank you for the question and I'll get
to it. But Dr. Naik keeps getting the
questions that should be come to the to
the Christian.
It says that on the next day, when it
was one after the preparation, the chief
priests and the Pharisees gathered
together with Pilate
and said, "Sir, we remember that when he
was still alive, that deceiver said,
'After 3 days, I'm to rise again.'
Therefore, give orders for the grave to
be made secure until the third day."
So, they're using these words
interchangeably.
As far as I'm concerned, all of these
words, the third day, after the third
day,
equal what happened with Jesus in the
grave.
The other thing is and then it's
resurrection.
There is one other thing.
When Jesus was arrested on Thursday
night,
Please be quiet. This is not going to
work like this. Please be patient.
Thursday and when and Thursday after he
when he was arrested, he said, "My time
my hour has come."
And so, I count that that's three and a
three days and three nights.
Now, you've asked me about these places
in the Bible.
I believe the Bible was written by God
and I believe that God put them in
there.
So, I it's not up to me to explain what
God said, but I believe that God put
those things in his Bible.
Yes. Now, we will have the last question
on the mic
from the brother at the back for Dr.
Zakir. Then we start the questions on
index cards.
That's the last question as per our time
limitations, please.
Okay. For Dr. Zakir. As-salamu alaykum.
Um
my name is Aslam Aroop and I'm a student
studying biology right now and my
teacher is teaching me evolution now and
I was wondering about the Islamic answer
to evolution right now. If you could
explain briefly
what Islam says on the topic of
evolution and creationism.
The brother asked a question.
Just in the Dr. William Campbell is
taking the liberty to answer even I'll
take the liberty. Nowhere in the Quran
is the name of Alexander mentioned. It
says Dhu al-Qarnain, not Alexander. If
some commentator made a mistake, it's a
mistake in the commentary. The men have
made the mistake, not the word of God.
Regarding the Bible saying that the
world in Isaiah is a circle, no problem.
It says circle, not spherical.
So, one place Bible says flat, one place
it says circle. If you agree both the
verses, it becomes like a disc.
See? Does it look like the earth?
It is circle and it's flat.
This is NOT THE EARTH.
REGARDING BIOLOGY IN THE QURAN and
regarding evolution, two questions the
brother asked. I don't know whether I
can answer both or not. I don't mind.
One, which one? First one or second one?
Biology or evolution? Evolution will be
good.
Evolution will be
Are you choosing or he's choosing?
Because he had the question for
evolution, I think it'll be good.
Two questions, biology first then
evolution. If you give me 10 minutes,
I'll answer both. Only in 5 minutes,
whatever you can do.
Okay, fine. I agree with the
chairperson, Mr. Samuel Noman. I'll
answer on evolution. The exact answer
you can refer to my video as I said,
Quran and modern science. Regarding when
you talk about evolution, you start
thinking about Darwin's theory. And
Darwin went on a ship, HMS Beagle, to
island by the name of Calotropis, and he
saw birds pecking
at niches. Based on that observation
that the
beaks of the bird became long and short,
he propounded the natural selection. But
he wrote a letter to his friend, Thomas
Compton, in 19th century. He said that I
do not have proof to propound my natural
selection, but because it helped me in
classification of embryology of
rudimentary organs, I have put forth
this. Darwin's theory is not a fact at
all. It is only a theory, and I made it
very clear in the beginning of my talk.
Quran can go against theories.
Because theories take U-turns, but Quran
will not go against any established
fact.
And in our school, we are taught about
Darwin's theory as though it's A FACT.
IT'S NOT A FACT.
There's no scientific PROOF AT ALL.
THERE ARE missing links. Therefore, if
someone has to insult his friend, his
colleague, he will say, "If you were
present at Darwin's time, Darwin's
theory would have been proved right."
Insulting, he looks like an ape.
There are missing LINKS IN DARWIN'S
THEORY.
And I know about the four fossils that
are present, the hominoids, the Lucy,
Australopithecus, which is guide, the
Homo erectus, Neanderthal man,
Cro-Magnon. For details, refer to my
video cassette. My molecular biology,
according to Hans Cregg, HE SAID IT IS
IMPOSSIBLE THAT WE CAN be evolved from
apes by DNA coding. It's impossible. You
can refer to my video cassette. It gives
the detail. Some parts I've got no
objection regarding biology. Quran says
in Surah Anbiya, chapter 21, verse
number 30,
"We have created every living thing from
water. Will you not then believe?" Today
we know that every living creature, the
basic substance, the cell, contains
cytoplasm, which has about 90% water.
Every living creature in the world has
approximately 50 to 90% water. Imagine,
in the deserts of Arabia, who could have
imagined that everything is made of
water? Quran said that 1400 years ago.
Time Dr. Naik.
Please, thank you. Thank you very much.
We will now start the questions on slips
of uh
We would have this box for Dr. William
Campbell, this box for Dr. Zakir Naik.
We turn the boxes, their names toward
themselves so they don't see through
while you all can see. They pick up the
questions looking away from the box and
they answer it themselves. Whatever
they choose, they have to answer. The
first question for Dr. William Campbell.
And the next question for Dr. Zakir.
They can pick up the questions in
advance so that we don't waste time in
the reading the questions. So, one one
question they can start and we'll allow
Dr. William to read for some time if he
wants to the first question.
I will read the question, but first I
just want to say about everything made
of water.
It's perfectly obvious. Every time you
smash a bug, it's made of water. Every
living thing is made of water, but it's
observable. It's not a miracle.
Okay, Dr. Campbell.
If you cannot answer the contradictions
in Genesis regarding the creation, don't
you think that the that proves that the
Bible is unscientific and therefore not
from God?
I admit that I have some problems with
this, but I also have all the fulfilled
prophecies.
And that's very important to me.
And Jesus And it says that
Jesus is the first cornerstone and built
on it and he's built on the foundation
of the apostles and the prophets.
And so the the prophets prophesied and
the apostles wrote down when God
fulfilled the prophecy.
I know that doesn't answer your
question,
but it my faith is in Christ for as my
savior.
Okay, thank you, Dr. Naik.
Text and translation are two different
words giving two different meanings
in the Bible in English a text or a
translation can scientifically text and
translation be proved to be the one and
the same? Did Did reveal his messages
upon Moses and Jesus, peace be upon them
upon them in English?
It's a very good question. Can the text
and translation be the same? No.
A text and translation cannot be exactly
the same, can come close to it. And
according to Maulana Abdul Majid
Daryabadi, he said, "The most difficult
book in the world to translate is the
glorious Quran."
Because the language of the Quran is so
eloquent. It is so superior, so noble.
And one word in Arabic has got several
meanings.
Therefore, to translate the Quran is the
most difficult. It is not the same. And
if there's a mistake in the translation,
it is a human handiwork. The human being
who's translating, he's to blame, not
Almighty God.
Regarding was Bible revealed in English?
No.
Bible was in
revealed in English. It's Old Testament
in Hebrew, New Testament in Greek.
Though Jesus Christ, peace be upon him,
spoke Hebrew, but the original
manuscript that you have, it's in Greek.
The Old Testament, the original Hebrew
is not available. Do you know that? The
Hebrew translation of the Old Testament
is from the Greek. So, even the original
Old Testament, which is in Hebrew, is
not present in Hebrew. So, you have a
double problem. No wonder you have
scribal errors, etc. But the Quran,
alhamdulillah, the original Arabic is
maintained. It has been, alhamdulillah,
scientifically you can prove it is the
same. And regarding were revelations
revealed to Jesus Christ, peace be upon
him, and to Moses, peace be upon him? I
said in my earlier answer as well as my
talk, that we believe, the Quran says,
in Surah Ar-Ra'd, chapter 13, verse 38,
that Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala has sent
down several revelations. By name, only
four are mentioned: the Torah, the
Zabur, the Injil, and the Quran. The
Torah is the Wahy which was given to
Moses, peace be upon him. The Zabur is
the revelation, the Wahy, which was
given to David, peace be upon him. Injil
is the Wahy, the revelation, which was
given to Jesus, peace be upon him. And
Quran is the last and final revelation
which was given to the last and final
messenger Prophet Muhammad, peace be
upon him.
Thank you, Dr. Naik. Thank you so much.
present not the Injil which we believe
in which was given to Jesus Christ,
peace be upon Thank you, sir.
Dr. Campbell.
May we have one more?
But the present Injil is the one that's
always been.
We have We have
texts
75% of the text from 180 AD.
That's 100 years after John wrote. He
was dead He was alive and wrote.
You have people alive at that point who
knew
who their their their grandparents
believed through John.
There's good evidence and good text. The
Bible is valid history.
Now, the question.
With the probability you presented, it
is a great calculation. Thank you.
But in the matter of
of
of God, it is completely inferior. God
is all powerful and can choose who he
likes, of course.
No matter rich or poor or any other
thing.
So, how then does your probability fit
in?
Jesus was poor. He was chosen. He said
the son of man has nowhere to lay his
head.
I'm not sure about this. I don't see how
the calculation is talking about that.
Calculation was how many people could
fill fulfill all those prophecies.
I hope that that's been helpful.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dr. Naik.
Go ahead, please. Go ahead. Thank you.
To an effort to prove in an effort to
prove the Quran is so or agreeable to
modern science, what happens if modern
science is wrong? Does the Quran always
change to reflect the changes in
science?
That's a very good question.
It's a very important question. And we
Muslims should be very careful while
being compatible with the Quran modern
science.
Therefore, I said in the beginning of my
talk, I will only be speaking about
those scientific facts which have been
established. And a scientific fact which
have been established, for example, the
earth is spherical. It can never go
wrong. Established science can never
take U-turns. But unestablished science,
like hypothesis and theories, can take
U-turns. I know Muslim scholars who have
tried to prove Darwin's theory from the
Quran.
Nonsense. So therefore, we should not go
overboard and try and prove everything
of modern science. We have to be careful
to check up whether it's established or
unestablished. If it's established,
alhamdulillah, with scientific proof,
the Quran will never go against it. If
it's hypothesis, it may be right, it may
be wrong. Like Big Bang theory. It was
hypothesis early.
Early it was hypothesis. Today, after
solid proof about the celestial matter,
according to Stephen Hawking etc., IT'S
A FACT. SO BIG BANG THEORY, TODAY IS A
FACT. Yesterday it was hypothesis. ONCE
IT BECOMES A FACT, I USE IT.
You know, there are hypotheses saying
that human beings have been created from
a single pair of genes, Adam and Eve.
I don't use it.
Because science hasn't established. It
goes along with the Quran. It goes along
with the Quran that we have been evolved
from one pair, Adam and Eve, peace be
upon them. But I don't use it because
that is not an established fact. So
therefore, while bringing a correlation
between Quran and science etc., see to
it that you use only those scientific
facts which have been established and
not hypothesis because Quran is far
superior to modern science. I'm not
trying to prove the Quran to be the word
of God with the help of science. No. Not
at all. What I'm trying do, for us
Muslims, Quran is the ultimate criteria.
For the atheist
and for the non-Muslims, maybe, science
may be the ultimate criteria.
What I'm doing, I'm using the criteria,
the yardstick of the atheist, and
comparing with the yardstick of the
Muslim, the Quran.
I'm not trying to prove the Quran to be
the word of God with help of science.
What I'm trying to do, when I bring a
compatibility, and I show the
superiority of Quran, that what your
science has told us yesterday, Quran has
told us 1,400 years ago. I'm trying to
prove that our yardstick,
the Muslim's yardstick, the Quran, is
far superior to your yardstick, the
science. Therefore, you should believe
in Quran, which is far superior. Hope
that answers the question. Thank you,
Dr. Naik.
Yes, Dr. Campbell. This is the last
Excuse me. Last two questions for the
speaker. We'd ask the audience to just
bear for us for a few minutes more. We
have the last question on the slip for
Dr. Campbell,
followed by one last question for Dr.
Zakir, and we'll ask you to please wait
till the end.
It's the same question as the last one,
really.
Dr. Campbell agreed to Dr. Naik that the
errors he showed are not wrong, and that
he can't answer them.
So, does this mean that Dr. Campbell
agrees that the Bible has errors?
So, it's not the word of God.
There are things in the Bible that I
can't explain, that I don't have an
answer for now.
And I'm willing to wait until I see
whether an answer comes.
There's many places where archaeological
things have proved that the Bible is
true, talking about towns and who was
king and things like that. And I think
there's great proof that the Bible is
valid and good history.
Thank you, Dr. Campbell. Just one
minute.
Okay, sure.
The question is, are there any more
mathematical contradictions
in the Bible? What is
Bible or Islam? Sorry. Are there any
more mathematical contradiction in
Islam?
Are there any more?
Is it Bible or Islam? I don't know. I'll
answer both.
Well, is there any more? It should be
Bible because I spoke about
contradiction. Anyway, regarding Islam,
the Quran says in Surah Nisa, chapter 4,
verse number 82, "Do
they not consider the Quran with care?
Had it been from anyone besides Allah,
there would have been many
contradictions. There is not a single
regarding more contradictions
in the Bible, 5 minutes will be
insufficient. Even if they give me 5
days, it's difficult. Anyway, I'll just
mention a few. It's mentioned in the
second Kings, chapter number 8,
verse number 26, it says that Ahaziah,
that Ahaziah, he was 22 years old when
he began to reign. Second Chronicles,
chapter number 22, verse number two says
that he was 42 years old when he began
to reign. Was he 22 years old or was he
42 years old?
Mathematical contradiction. Furthermore,
in second Chronicles, chapter number 21,
verse number 20, it says that Joram, the
father of Ahaziah, he reigned at the age
of 32 and he reigned for 8 years and he
died at the age of 40.
Immediately, Ahaziah
became the next ruler at the age of 42.
Father died
at the age of 40. Immediately, son takes
over who's at the age OF 42.
HOW CAN A SON BE 2 years older than the
father.
Believe me, even even in Hollywood film
you will not be able TO PRODUCE IT.
IN HOLLYWOOD FILM, YOU CAN PRODUCE a
unicorn which I mentioned in my talk,
unicorn. You can have cockatrices which
the Bible speaks about, cockatrices and
and dragons and serpents. But in
Hollywood, you cannot even show a son
being 2 years older than the father. It
cannot even be a miracle. Even in
miracle it's not possible. Impossible.
In miracle you can have a person being
born of a virgin birth, but in miracle
you can't have a son being older than
the father by 2 years.
Further, if you read
it's mentioned in the Bible in 2 Samuel
chapter number 24, verse number 9, that
the people that were involved
in the battlefield, it gives a list of
these people in 2 Samuel chapter 24,
verse number 9, and it says that people
that took part, 800,000 of the men of
Israel took part.
And 500,000 of the men of Judah.
Same, if you see other places, 1
Chronicles chapter 21, verse number 5,
it says that
1 million 100,000
people took part
in the battlefield from the men of
Israel. And 10,460
men took part of Judah. Was it 800,000
people who took part from the men of
Israel? Or was it 1 million 100,000? Was
it 5 lakh people of Judah that took
part? Or 10,460?
A clear-cut contradiction.
Furthermore
it's mentioned
in the Bible
in
2 Samuel chapter number 6, verse number
23, that Michelle
the daughter of Saul, she had no sons.
2 Samuel chapter 21, verse number 8,
Michelle the daughter of Saul had five
sons.
One place it says no children,
no son, no daughter, other place five
sons.
Furthermore, if you read,
it's mentioned
in Gospel of Matthew, chapter number
one, verse number 16,
it says about the genealogy of Jesus,
peace be upon him, as well as Luke
chapter number three, verse number 23,
and it says that Jesus' father, the
Joseph, his father was Jacob, Matthew
chapter one verse 16. And Luke chapter
three verse number 23, Jesus' FATHER,
JOSEPH, HIS FATHER was Heli. Did Jesus'
father, Joseph, have two fathers?
What do you call a person who has got
two fathers? Or was it Heli or was it
Jacob? Thank you very much for your
cooperation. Thank you very much.
Uh can we can we have you bear with us
for two minutes? We have
the renowned international Islamic
scholar amongst us, Dr. Jamal Badawi,
and on behalf of the Islamic Research
Foundation,
we feel it an honor if he would take
the pleasure of inaugurating or
releasing the book just written by Dr.
Zakir Naik,
The Quran and Modern Science, Compatible
or Incompatible.
Dr. Jamal Badawi to uh
release the book
which has just recently been published
and printed few days back, and being
released here in Chicago on this
appropriate occasion. And I think there
is no
more fitting way as a gesture of
friendship than to ask Dr. Zakir to give
it to Dr. Campbell by himself.
As we have a very limited number of
these copies available, so we would
request only the non-Muslim guests who
have come here
to kindly take a complimentary copy of
the book as they leave the auditorium if
they're interested. It would be a
pleasure.
May I call upon Dr. Sabeel Ahmed to
present the vote of thanks.
Again, on behalf of Islamic Circle of
North America,
I would really thank all of you for your
patience and all our esteemed guests
over here
for giving us a very good performance
for all of us.
Oh my creator, oh Allah, fulfill our
aims in life, Allah. Forgive our sins,
yeah, Allah. Oh Allah, the most
gracious.